bruno cautrès politologue chercheur cnrs
au cevipof spécialiste des comportements
et des attitudes politiques
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors c'est vrai
que tu es spécialiste des questions
écologiques n'ont pas vraiment été
convaincu par le discours des manuels
mettront les français n'ont plus
décidément la suspicion est tenace oui
c'est clair vous savez les spécialistes
de comportements politiques utilisent
souvent une notion ils disent que pour
que les électeurs croient dans
l'engagement d'un parti politique d'un
candidat dans sa sincérité
il faut qui lui est attribuée avant
cette spécialité
les électeurs vont spéciales vont dire
que la gauche va c'est elle qui a qui
peut traiter les questions de justice
sociale de lutte contre les inégalités
la droite avec le business la
compétitivité de l'économie l'ordre
public
et lorsque les français pensent écologie
réchauffement climatique questions
environnementales ben il trouve que
c'est plutôt les verts qui s'en occupent
donc on voit qu emmanuel macron à un
challenge qui est extrêmement important
qui est de le convaincre effectivement à
la fois de la sincérité mais aussi de la
crédibilité de son engagement économique
après tout emmanuel macron a fixé des
objectifs très ambitieux mais après tout
il lui reste moins de deux ans pour
effectuer ces objectifs dans le cadre de
notre premier quinquennat
finalement ça s'appelle un préjugé voilà
allez les verts c'est pour l'écologie je
suis social pour la gauche c'est ce
qu'on fait un faux procès selon vous à
emmanuel macron si on va plus loin que
des peintres ou faux procès après tout
emmanuel macron nelly moins bien ni
mieux placé que d'autres hommes ou
femmes politiques pour parler de
l'écologie aujourd'hui tout le monde
parle de l'écologie mais c'est
simplement que les français vont
reconnaître aux écologistes à des
personnalités comme nicolas hulot
comme yannick jadot eelv on les créditer
de la la longueur de leur engagement
si vous prenez quelqu'un comme yannick
jadot ou comme nicolas hulot ils ont
fait l'intégralité de leur carrière
militante de leur engagement dans dans
dans la sphère publique au service de
cette cause de de l'ecologie on peut pas
dire que ça soit le cas d'emmanuel macro
qui a d'abord et avant tout voulu
incarner à la fois la compétitivité de
l'économie française de réconcilier la
france et les français avec la la
mondialisation est par ailleurs les
français ont quand même encore en toile
de fond sommes en mémoire le départ de
nicolas hulot du gouvernement emmanuel
macron était arrivé à recruter celui que
tout le monde voulait faire entrer dans
un gouvernement
alors c'est vrai que ça a testé de
l'importance que emmanuel macron accordé
à cet enjeu mais justement on a retenu
qu'il n'a pas su garder le nicolas hulot
j'allais venir quand vous l'avez
souhaité nicolas hulot c'est peut-être
cet épisode qui a tout changé
effectivement 66 % des français pensent
que le chef de l'état n'en a pas fait
assez notamment pour le climat au début
de son quinquennat
c'est là selon vous que la machine s'est
enrayée il ya eu ensuite le départ
tonitruant en c2 de françois de rugy une
série de malchances pour voir emmanuel
macron sur le plan de l'écologie
en tout cas c'est clair qu'il ya eu une
séquence très difficile pour emmanuel
macron vous le rappelez vous avez raison
départ de nicolas hulot départ de france
rue de rugy le ministre de la transition
écologique y remplacer nicolas hulot et
puis la crise des gilet jaune qui s'est
fait initialement aux départs sur des
questions de deux taxes qui concernait
le diesel l'essence les 80 km donc on
voit que cet enjeux climatiques
environnementales est un enjeu
effectivement sur lequel emmanuel
macouin du mal à trouver son rythme de
croisière
aujourd'hui il nous dit qu'il souhaite
finir ces deux dernières années en
mettant la gomme en allant vraiment très
très très très vite et très loin sur
l'écologie je pense que beaucoup
de beaucoup de français attendent de
devoir à la fois qu'elles seront les
engagements qu'elle quelles seront les
conséquences budgétaires aussi de ces de
ces décisions qui sont attendus fort
évidemment plus récemment aux
municipales le derrière
oui bien sûr il n'a guère de choix au
fond emmanuel macron a au cours de son
mandat en partie perdu le soutien du
centre gauche qui pourtant avait
contribué de manière absolument décisive
à son élection il a récupéré une partie
du centre droit mais on voit que pour
gagner l'élection présidentielle se
qualifier au deuxième tour il lui faudra
sans doute reconquérir des parts des
lectorats ils voient sans doute avec
quelque inquiétude monte progressivement
à la fois le thème de l'écologie mais
aussi à travers les élections
municipales on n'a vu non seulement des
victoires de l'écologie dans certaines
des grandes villes françaises et non des
moindres bordeaux par exemple strasbourg
mais aussi la bienvenue à mon avis à
travers les élections municipales qui
était en train de se mettre en place une
nouvelle dynamique
rose verte et des fois un peu rouge
d'ailleurs autour d'une sorte 2-2
nouvelle union de la gauche municipale
avec un effet d'entraînement des
écologistes et ça je pense que du point
de vue sa stratégie politique s'inquiète
emmanuel macron justement les
écologistes devenir des concurrents
sérieux challenger sérieux à la
présidentielle aujourd'hui
alors il faut pas tout de suite sauté
pas je pense qu'il ya deux erreurs à ne
pas faire la première erreur serait de
sauter le pas immédiatement des
municipales vers la présidentielle en
disant il ya un boulevard qui attend une
candidature écologiste l'autre erreur ça
serait au contrat de dire ces élections
municipales forte abstention n'étaient
que des scrutins locaux et de veulerie
au plan national c'est entre les deux il
s'est passé quelque chose à travers ces
élections municipales et c'est sans
aucun doute autour de ces questions que
emmanuel macron aura sans doute le de la
delà de la concurrence il veut venir sur
le thème écologistes et le thème de
l'écologie et je pense que les
principales forces politiques qui est
également veulent incarner l'écologie se
rappelleront à son bon souvenir au
moment de la présidentielle
merci beaucoup bruno cautrès politologue
chercheur au cevipof d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france